se sumerge sin tregua para explorar el
fondo del sena y es muy raro que la
pinza del vélez no salga del agua con
las manos vacías sacamos del agua una
caja fuerte se la robaron y le cortaron
el fondo por la parte de atrás con una
moradora eso quiere decir que los
ladrones tiran esto a escena así para
evitar dejar rastros huellas y todo eso
cajas fuertes televisores viejos
patinetas muebles
el capitán del log y su equipo se
encargan de esta pesca poco apetitosa
aquí tenemos otras cosas esto no para
todos los días pero en lo que ya te
pusimos aquí en un área de 50 a 60
metros del arroyo bet de lobo y la zona
cubrir es amplia unos 60 kilómetros
barridos por este barco des contaminador
que le pertenece al departamento de los
altos del sena cada año se recogen
alrededor de 360 toneladas de desechos a
veces es necesario desembarcar para
jalar los con las manos
y una moto esto está lleno de
hidrocarburos eso contamina la fauna y
la flora mata las plantas acuáticas
destruye los jueces así que la situación
es muy bueno ese día fue imposible sacar
el vehículo de dos ruedas es demasiado
pesado pero los dos marineros se van con
un carrito de supermercado potencial
obstáculo para la navegación cuando está
demasiado cerca puede enredarse en las
hélices en realidad es un peligro para
todo el mundo setecientos mil euros es
el presupuesto anual del departamento de
los saltos de escena para descontaminar
esta parte del río al oeste de parís a
bordo del belenos la tripulación realiza
una primera selección para reciclar la
mayor cantidad posible de desechos el
sena como basurero para algunos
franceses no es una novedad
el escena libre y 6 otra obsesión uno
debe recurrir a las vibras de gallo y
pablo desde tiempos inmemoriales el río
ha sido un caos acuático el reflejo del
estilo de vida de cada época lo que
ahora emerge de las aguas son las
bicicletas y las patinetas eléctricas en
parís en los muelles del canal de luz
cada mes se reúnen los curiosos
alrededor de la barcaza de gregory peck
este jefe de empresa se lanzó sobre un
nuevo mercado el rescate de vehículos de
autoservicio con la ayuda de un bus o el
buceador podrá detectar los objetos
agarrar los comunes que tony y ayudar a
que los saquen gregory peck firmó un
contrato con los operadores que
distribuyen sus patinetas por la capital
la ciudad de parís los obliga a
recuperar las que les pertenecen las que
se tiran al agua siempre se alcanza una
cantidad de industrial hoy vamos a haber
sacado unos 70 patinetas y en total la
causa el vandalismo y la falta de
civismo de algunos usuarios
comportamientos denunciados por los
transeúntes
he visto gente tirarlas al río pero no
me parece que sea divertido hacerlo cada
operación le costaría tres mil
quinientos euros al mes a los operadores
en seis meses cerca de 500 vehículos han
sido sacados del sena o de los canales
parisinos y con frecuencia llegan a un
estado lamentable a los depósitos de su
propietario estamos en uno de los
talleres de mantenimiento es imposible
que esta patineta pueda volver a prestar
el servicio una vez desmontada algunos
componentes se volverán piezas de
repuesto las otras serán recicladas aquí
están todas las partes reutilizables
todo lo que está hecho de acero aluminio
y plástico fue desmontado y solo está
sucio pero que es posible limpiar y
reutilizar por ejemplo la cabecera los
manubrios etcétera y aquí están las
partes que no son reutilizables todo
electrónico esta pieza la pantalla el
acelerómetro que viene aquí estuvieron
sumergidos demasiado tiempo entonces no
es posible reutilizarlos los llevaremos
a la cadena de reciclaje posiblemente la
pieza más contaminante para el medio
ambiente la batería de litio también
terminará en una cadena de reciclaje
especializada
será posible nadar algún día en estas
aguas sin estos estorbosos desechos en
el marco de los juegos olímpicos' de
2024 la ciudad de parís asumió un reto
organizar las pruebas de nado libre en
un cena limpio